Disney Channel is king when it comes to
creating beloved TV shows like Hannah
Montana Jesse and Wizards of Waverly
Place but that doesn't explain why some
of their most popular series got
canceled without a moment's notice
why did Andy Mack end after just three
short seasons and why wasn't the
spin-off series of Boy Meets World as
successful as the original keep watching
to find out the mind-blowing reasons why
your favorite Disney Channel shows got
dropped from actor disputes and
spontaneous arrests to creative
differences and low ratings find out the
real reasons these shows got cut back in
2011 Disney Channel had big hopes for
its TV show prank stars the reality
series starred Disney alum mitchel Musso
who served as the host for the show's
first and only season this series was
different than what Disney Channel was
used to first of all it aired monthly
and was filmed with a hidden camera the
concept of the show revolved around
young fans meeting their favorite Disney
stars in the most ridiculous and
hilarious settings these kids were
nominated by their friends and family
members and the first few episodes of
prank stars reunited fans with
celebrities like Selena Gomez debby ryan
china anne mcclain bella thorne and many
more this hilarious show got off to a
great start
it aired its first episode on September
30th 2011 and a total of four episodes
would be released before the show was
taken off the air so what caused Disney
Channel to pull the plug on prank stars
well mitchel Musso was arrested for
driving under the influence in
mid-october putting a stain on the
Disney Channel name the last two
episodes of prank stars had never aired
in the United States however they did
air in the UK
[Music]
Wizards of Waverly Place starred Selena
Gomez David Henry and Jake Tiana's Alex
Justin and max Russo the series would go
on to have a spectacular four seasons
each one better than the last now we
know that Disney Channel isn't a fan of
creating shows that have more than three
seasons but every now and then a popular
series comes along and breaks the mold
Wizards of Waverly Place followed three
Wizards siblings who were constantly
competing to become the sole owner of
their family's powers the show won
countless awards and was a total hit it
also boosted Selena Gomez into the
limelight helping her become the star
she was meant to be the show was so
successful Disney Channel was ready to
renew it for a fifth season however the
teen stars felt like it was time for
them to move on and start planning their
futures many of them were ready to throw
in their towels and head off to college
so without its main actors Disney
Channel had no choice but to wrap the
series Boy Meets World is one of the
most beloved sitcoms from the 90s with
this in mind Disney Channel decided to
create a spin-off series called Girl
Meets World Ben savage and danielle
fishel reprised their roles as Cory and
Topanga Matthews and the series focus on
the life of their children Riley and
Auggie who were played by Rowan
Blanchard and August maturo respectively
the spin-off also starred actors like
the Sabrina carpenter and Peyton Mayer
despite the show's stellar cast and
promising reputation Disney Channel soon
found out that spin-offs were gamble
Girl Meets World had a total of three
seasons each one Bri and fewer ratings
in the last soon became clear that the
show wasn't going to be a home run like
the original to make matters worse there
were friction between the cast one of
the biggest feuds was between Uriah
Shelton and Rowan Blanchard Rowan who is
a feminist constantly bumped heads with
Uriah who is known for liking
anti-feminist post on Instagram actor
disputes and low ratings are what led to
Girl Meets World getting cancelled after
just three seasons
No sunny with a chance sunny with a
chance quickly became everyone's
favorite Disney Channel show back in
2009 and how could it not it did start
Demi Lovato after all Demi played the
lovable and talented sunny Monroe who
had recently become a cast member of the
comedy show so random sunny with a
chance is one of the few dissing Channel
shows to feature a show within a show
which gave it more depth and pizzazz the
series also starred Tiffany Thornton as
Tony Hart and Sterling Knight as Chad
Dylan Cooper fans were stunned to win
decent Channel announced that sunny with
the chance would be canceled after just
two short seasons however they had
little choice in the matter of
considering that their star Demi Lovato
had chosen to leave Disney Channel to
pursue a singing career but Disney
executives remained hopeful deciding to
create a spin-off series called so
random sadly this spin-off turned out to
be a huge mistake the show received poor
ratings resulting in so random getting
cancelled after just one season Jessie
one of Disney Channel's biggest hits
will forever be Jessie this hilarious
family sitcom starred debby ryan as
Jessie Prescott
Peyton lists as Emma Karen Brar as Revie
Skye Jackson Azzurri and the late and
beloved Cameron Boyce as Luke Jessie
would air for a total of four seasons
and many of the cast members would
reprise their roles in the spin-off show
bunked Jessie fans were bummed to find
out that the show would wrap up after
just four seasons but debby ryan took to
twitter to explain that the show had run
its course and that it was time for her
to move on
Debbie Ryan was more than ready to leave
her disney channel days behind her she
told fans that she wanted to focus on
her friends and family members for a
change she also congratulated her
co-stars for receiving their own show
which would go on to have a total of
four seasons to Disney Channel's Jessie
wasn't canceled for scandalous or
repulsive reasons but the same can't be
said about Andy Mack watching to the end
to find out which cast member ruined the
show's golden reputation we made a
pretty good team the best
Hannah Montana Disney Channel has the
secret recipe when it comes to creating
celebrities many of their leading ladies
go on to become huge stars once they
sever ties with the Disney Channel name
this was the case for Miley Cyrus who
rose to fame on the set of Hannah
Montana from 2006 to 2011 the sitcom
starred Miley Cyrus as Miley Stewart aka
Hannah Montana Emily Osment as Louis
Truscott Jason Earles as Jaxon Stewart
Billy Ray Cyrus as Robby ray Stewart and
mitchel Musso and Oliver Oken
all in all Hannah Montana received
amazing ratings throughout his forces in
front which made the show's cancellation
all the more surprising in the end Miley
Cyrus was growing up at an alarming
speed and quickly growing tired of the
many rules Disney Channel stars had to
follow she opted for a more mature image
causing critics to believe that she was
a bad example for young kids despite the
show's huge following Disney had no
choice but to cancel it Liv and Maddie
Liv and Maddie aired for a total of four
seasons from 2013 to 2017 the show had a
fun concept and start dove Cameron as
both Liv and Maddie Rooney the series
followed a pair of identical twins with
opposing personalities dove Cameron
would go on to become the face of The
Descendants franchise after Liv and
Maddie aired its final episode in 2017
still fans were curious as to why such a
hilarious and unique sitcom got the boot
after just four seasons as it turns out
ratings started to dip after season 3
causing the show's creator Ron Hart to
announce that the series would not be
renewed for a fifth and final season
Disney Channel rushed to wrap up any
loose ends on Liv and Maddie and most
viewers were happy with the finale
Casey under cover Casey under cover
quickly became one of the most watched
TV shows on Disney Channel the series
ran from 2015 to 2018 and had a total of
three seasons but fans would have
preferred of Casey Undercover had
continued for another season or two
however due to the nature of the show
and how it came to be three seasons were
all that zendaya could commit to zendaya
had previously starred on Disney Channel
she
get up with bella thorne but when the
show got cancelled zendaya chose to
leave the Disney Channel family she felt
as though Disney failed to represent
families of color and lost interest in
working with them that is until Disney
Channel executives agreed to create a
show that revolved around a family of
color while giving zendaya some creative
freedom zendaya returned to give viewers
the family sitcom they deserved however
she didn't plan on sticking around
forever zendaya was more than ready to
move and after three seasons Kacey
undercover wrapped up production after
filming 76 episodes and zendaya left to
pursue new and more mature endeavors
Lizzie McGuire
Hilary Duff was one of Disney Channel's
first ever stars and her show Lizzie
McGuire was a total hit the sitcom aired
from 2001 to 2004 and had a total of two
seasons and 65 episodes for a long time
fans of the show wondered why Disney
Channel chose to cancel Lizzie McGuire
despite its incredible success after all
the series was such a hit it would go on
to have a movie and tons of merchandise
maintenance honor in the end contract
disagreements between Disney executives
and Hilary Duff are what led to the
show's termination contract attitude and
eMac Disney Channel executives know how
to handle scandal but they could never
be prepared for the scandal that rocked
the Andy Mac show Andy Mack started
Peyton Elizabeth Lee as Andy lilium boat
in his Bex Joshua rush as Cyrus Asher
Angels Jonah and Sophia Wiley as Buffy
fans couldn't get enough of the show
which came to an abrupt end in 2019 for
the most despicable reason although
Disney Channel executives will say that
the series was ready to wrap up after
just three seasons the ratings disproved
that theory now in reality actor Stoney
Westmoreland who played Andy's
grandfather on the show was arrested and
charged with 6 felony charges in 2018
when he attempted to have relations with
a minor the scandal was so shocking
Disney had no choice but to wrap up
production as soon as possible
that's awful and that's a wrap on why
these Disney Channel shows got cancelled
before you go tell us which show was
your favorite in the comments below
thanks for watching the things be sure
to LIKE and subscribe for more we'll see
you next time
you